fue la mayor manifestación jamás
organizada en francia según el ministro
del interior de la época el país se vio
sacudido por ataques mortales 12
personas fueron asesinadas en un ataque
a charlie hebdo y cuatro rehenes
asesinados en una tienda kosher dos días
después
françois hollande entonces presidente
llamó a la unidad sin saber que ese
sería sólo el comienzo de una oleada de
atentados terroristas en territorio
francés el 13 de noviembre de 2015
francia enfrentó los atentados más
mortíferos de su historia 130 personas
murieron en parís una masacre organizada
por el autodenominado estado islámico el
presidente alan declaró inmediatamente
el estado de emergencia francés está en
guerra los actos cometidos en parís y
cerca del estadio de francia son actos
de guerra fue prolongado tres veces y le
daba a gobierno poderes extraordinarios
incluyendo el derecho de registrar
locales sin una orden judicial en 2017
el gobierno de manuel ma chrome adoptó
una ley de seguridad para sustituir el
estado de emergencia facilitando el
control de individuos y restringiendo su
libertad de movimiento
el plan de peak y piggott pasó de tener
dos niveles a tener tres actualmente se
encuentra en nivel 2 seguridad reforzada
y riesgo de atentado desde 2015 se han
presentado 17 ataques clasificados como
actos terroristas en territorio francés
entre ellas se encuentra la masacre del
14 de julio de 2016 en niza cuando un
hombre arrasó una multitud con un camión
o el tiroteo en el mercado de navidad de
estrasburgo en 2018 desde la pérdida de
territorio del grupo yihadista estado
islámico los observadores creen que su
capacidad para dirigir operaciones a
gran escala ha disminuido pero su
ideología sigue extendiéndose en
internet con la introducción de los
archivos s las autoridades están
vigilando a las personas sospechosas de
ser una amenaza para la seguridad
nacional